I'm not the smartest kid in the world
okay it says somebody saying oh no
you're smart no no I don't say that to
yourself I said to myself no I'm a dumb
okay Roger that and I think I'm the
hardest guy in the world you got to
believe that you gotta believe you are
something what whole thing about comfort
zones is if you live in one for too long
that becomes your norm
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that can change the planet
instead of help you on your journey
today we're going to learn from Navy
SEAL and ultra marathon runner
David Goggins and my take on his top ten
rules for success rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys liked the best
I came home one night from work spraying
for cockroaches and long story short I
turned on the Discovery Channel
and I saw some guys going through Navy
SEAL training and they're going through
hell week and they're getting their ass
just beat you know in out of the water
guys ringing the bell there was
suffering and I was waiting like 297
pounds and I had to make a change in my
life you know I was at all-time low and
I wasn't going anywhere
and I was exactly what everybody said I
was going to be which was nothing so I
had to make a change what was it about
seeing suffering us that's really
interesting and actually get it but I
want to hear you explain it why
suffering was the thing that triggered
that thought well for me growing up I
came from a horrible background I got
called [ __ ] every day of my life
growing up lived in a small town the
Klan headquarters at that time was about
20 minutes from where I lived the one of
the high ups in the KKK son sat behind
me in two classes so you called me [ __ ]
all the time I got my first car they
spray print [ __ ] we're going to kill
you on it so I was just an insecure
scared kid and the only way I could find
myself was to put myself through the
worst thing possible I'm gonna say the
exact opposite of what the world today's
world is saying so we read a bunch of
books nowadays as humans we we want to
find out how to be someone else what we
don't do is we don't go inside so
literally turn yourself inside out read
the book that says like we're writing a
book every day of our lives
every day we're seeing who we are as
people when I was growing up I I lied
for people to accept me because I didn't
accept myself so I would make up stories
so you so then you would accept me into
your world I would uh everything I did
was for someone else to like me
it was until I started reading my own
book about how pathetic I was as human
being I could blame my dad I can blame
kids at school I could blame having
health issues
ATD my mom not being a
great mom but she was doing her thing I
could blame a lot of people and that's
the book I was reading and I put it off
on everybody else it wouldn't so I say
you know what for me to fix this I get a
read what the hell what the [ __ ] is
wrong with David Goggin
not blame anybody read my books okay I'm
afraid of my shadow how can I overcome
that go in and military get your ass
kicked do things you hate to do be
uncomfortable every day of your life
Roger that I'm not the smartest kid in
the world okay it says somebody saying
oh no you're smart no no I don't say
that to yourself I said to myself no I'm
a dumb okay Roger that how do you get
smarter educate yourself so the things
that we run from we run from the truth
we run it from the truth man so the only
way I became successful was going
towards the truth as painful and as
brutal as it is it changed me it allowed
me to become in my own right who aim
today David tell him about the cookie
jar the cookie jar is something I
invented as you all know your mom has a
cookie jar and sometimes you might have
an Oreo sometimes you might have a Chips
of Hawaii sometimes you might have a
Oakland raisin cookie
you never know is this in there my
cookie jar has every single failure and
success of my life
sup my overcame so what happens in this
in time of life when you're stressed out
and things get bad even the hardest guy
in the world me everybody thinks and I
think I'm the hardest guy in the world
you got to believe that you got believe
you are something I will in my mind
reach into my cookie jar and sometimes
you forget how hard you are in times of
need because you're you're stressed but
you forget I'm a Navy SEAL I'm a ranger
I'm this and that but you forget all
that cuz your life sucks I calm down
take that one second get control of my
life reaching the cookie jar well you
got caught [ __ ] your whole life and
you're now the only person history do
justice
this put it back in the cookie jar reset
my mind you have to remind yourself of
how badass you really are in times of
need that's the cookie jar so many of us
are on cruise control myself included
and we get into our daily routine and
routines are unbelievable but routines
can also be a rut only if you really
challenge yourself and push yourself and
get out of your routine your comfort
zone can you get better like you can't
improve when you're on autopilot so you
have to set goals and you have to set
challenges that you don't necessarily
think you can do we're gonna push
yourself way further than you think you
can to improve so you got to get out of
the complacency of the routine whole
thing about comfort zones is if you live
in one for too long that becomes your
norm it never allows you to get
experience gained knowledge game any
kind of mental toughness well I learned
that we all have a reserve tank that
we're all capable of doing so much more
than we think we can and only by really
tapping into that reserve tank whether
it's in business whether it's in
physically you want to get more fit only
when you really push yourself and push
your limits can you find out what you're
really made of and what's in your
reserve tank and I mean he taught me
that every single day
and it just led to me getting better in
the various buckets in my life as I
tapped into that reserve tank yeah I
said don't be you know we call it the
40% rule that's something that David
kind of told me and shared with me and I
bought into it and it's but it's proved
effective not just in working out but
even in business or my family life it's
like when I'm frustrated when I'm done
when I hit a roadblock when things get
complicated you have so much more in you
people I said man you cuss all the time
why well I hate to say it the best way
for me to get how I feel across I can't
see really say you know what I went
through hell week and met it was it was
really hard no that takes your damn soul
rips it inside out and then they say now
we're going to start it it allows me to
express where I was at at a point of my
life if I won't give you all of me why
the hell am I here
why how will you learn from me people
take so much offense to me you will
never learn from people if we always
tap-dance around the truth oh god I love
that we tap-dance around the truth by
finding the right words I don't hurt you
because you have thin skin no tighten up
people it's okay
trust me it's okay you might be called
[ __ ] one day it's okay you might be
called some Jewish word or some [ __ ]
or gay word it's okay let them call you
that what are you going to do now they
don't own your life how are you going to
control that now how are you gonna flip
it upside down and say Roger that now
I'm going to harness this and you read
about me years from now how that's the
question how are you going to do that
thicken your skin become more of a human
being don't be afraid of the reflection
in the mirror because that's all you can
be afraid of once you overcome the
reflection in the mirror you've done it
literally broke all the metatarsals in
my feet stress fracture shin splints
everything the pain throw with my body
I've been through every chain another
man Ranger school helmet three times all
kind of stuff this event I'm explained
to you right now in enough time span to
you in detail was the worst thing I've
done in my entire life pain wise this is
when I realized my being is capable of
going to limits unknown to most people
this is where hardness comes in people
can read a book on hardness and tell you
about mental toughness and hardness but
until you put your body through hardness
and realize that there's walls and doors
you must break through and once you
break through them you are amazing and
your body resets but we are scared to
get to that wall because that wall says
what stop right but every wall has a
what
ador you got to get that keys with your
pocket and don't be scared assume so
those that are doing I would like to
know when you're in that moment failing
hmm and you have to keep going what do
you say to yourself what if a lot of
times I'll be in a tours at Mile Run or
something like that and I'm all jacked
up body's broken mines broken spirits
broken I started to say what if I can
pull this off when I first walked into
the Navy SEAL recruiters office he
looked at me and said only been 35
african-americans and 70 years make it
through you know I said to myself what
if I can be the 36 it's the what if I
can pull off a miracle what if I can
become someone that no one thinks I can
be and just that just me talking about
that I have the hair growing up on my
arms because it makes me just like what
if I can be that guy that people who
call [ __ ] and this and that and now
I'm speaking at tom ferry event what is
that's it so this the first
ultramarathon wasn't smart at all at all
just so basically happened was I was at
military freefall school with Morgan
Latrell marcus luttrell if you guys
don't know was the lone survivor the guy
he was in a bad op op went bad he was
the only navy so that lived long story
short you got to get the book read lone
survivor great story
Morgan is Marcus - Charles twin brother
and I was there with Marcus so what
happened was myself and Morgan were
freefall school at the same exact time
Marcus was in the worst incident in
still history so I knew that Marcus
might be dead he wasn't dead everybody
was dead so I actually bought Morgan you
know I actually told Morgan hey man your
brother wasn't a bad incident I don't
know if he's alive I know what's going
on long story short
Marcus is alive and I go on to want to
raise money for families all these guys
died they all had kids I want to raise
money for the Special Operations Warrior
Foundation it's a foundation where 100%
tuition goes to these kids to go to
college you know full tuition whatever
so I found this great foundation I'm
going to raise money for it
so I see no what I have to Google
something that's that's evil something
very hard I knew nothing about
ultramarathons
I hadn't even on a marathon I knew
nothing about this world so I googled
that did all the top 10 hardest races in
the world and what comes up is about
water 135 so hundred thirty-five mile
race through Death Valley in the
summertime I thought it was a stage race
I thought I was a race where you run
like 20 miles set up camp you know
barbecue outside and then go run some
more the next day so I called the race
director up at the race and said hey
Chris and there was Chris Causton I want
to do your race so we had a long
conversation you know I was I was much
heavier then and I had to put running
shoes on over a year I'll have area at
this point I'm around between 240 to 270
whoa I'm in there I'm in that register
I've my weight has buried a lot through
the SEAL Teams and I was so team so I
was a heavy guy but the long and short
of it all was I am put running shoes on
in over a year
I was a big-time power lifter I lifted
weights heavy that's what I did I got
back home from Iraq went straight to
freefall school and then this happened
so I called Chris costumed up on a
Wednesday he says look man the only way
you can qualify for my race is to run
100 miles at one time in 24 hours or
less there happened to be a race that
Saturday so four days later and he said
if you qualify by running a hundred
miles or less in 24 hours I will
consider you my race I'm gonna cut to
the chase I signed up for this race it's
called a San Diego one day where you run
around a one-mile track for 24 hours
two city miles you can get my goal was
100 miles so I got 2 miles 70 and I
cleared 70 miles in like 12 13 hours
pretty quickly but I was done my feet
were broken
I was stretched fractured shin splints
muscles were tearing I was in bad shape
I was eating rich crackers and drinks
his happy that's all I had no water
didn't know what the hell I was doing
out there had on some tube socks it was
just ridiculous it was it was a clown
show so I sat down at Mile 70 and at
this time I was married and I look at my
wife and I was like I'm messed up bad
so I literally start to turn white and
when a black guy turns white you're
pretty so here I am I'm all up in this
chair I'm at Mile 70 they got 30 miles
to go I'm jacked up I got to go to the
bathroom in the bathrooms like 20 feet
from me supporter party I can't get all
the chair so I'm peeing blood down my
leg whoa pooping up my back and I got 30
miles to go and I'm I can't stand up cuz
my my blood pressure's all messed up
I've been in three whole weeks Ranger
School overcome so many obstacles in my
life this last 30 miles of this race is
when I realized a human being is not so
human anymore we have the ability to go
in such a space if you're willing to
suffer
and I mean suffer your brain and your
body once connected together can do
anything and this 30 miles was the
life-changing moment I was out of it I
was in the worst pain in my entire life
I was to me on the brink of death and I
was able to Chuck this 30 damn miles
into small pieces I was so driven and
I'm not gonna say motivated cuz
motivation is crap motivation comes and
goes when you're driven whatever's in
front of you will get destroyed so I sat
in this chair and I was so driven to
succeed in this race and at this time
everyone's were you thinking about the
guys that died and I'm not gonna lie to
you I was it this became a personal
thing this became me against this race
me against the kids that called me
[ __ ] me against me it just became
something that I took so so violently
personal and I broke this thing down
into small pieces I said okay I got to
get nutrition I gotta be able to stand
up before I can get off this curve and
golf this chair and be able to go 30
miles so I went through all these small
steps and I was able to stand up and
then from standing up I was literally
walking around with my wife at the time
and she goes you not gonna make the time
she goes you mean you're walking like 37
minute miles I got tomorrow 81 and the
second she said that I'm not gonna make
the time I ran the last 19 miles
non-stop and I can show you right now
when we get done with this my fact I
want to show you right now this was
years ago and I had to put compression
tape on my own and I had so this was
years ago I had literally the size of
half dollars I had to get compression
tape and I taped up my ankles and i
taked up my feet and that's how I got
through that race it was like a hematoma
I mean what do we what happened was like
my shins hurts so bad from having stress
fractures that's the only way I could
continue on was I taped it so I wasn't
doing the
flexure motion that that activates your
shins so I take my ankles and my shins
up and I got that from because of my
throat hell week they were good let me
go back to you no train anymore right so
I literally went through all the buds my
last SEAL training with stress fractures
and shin splints and how I did it
was I would take my ankles all the way
up to my calf every morning so for the
first hour the pain was excruciating
but what happened is my feet would go
numb and I did that every single day for
six months whoa and that's how I got
through my third hell because I was so
broken from the first two that the
commander said hey the CEO said this
year last time I sent you through so
that's how I got the idea to do that so
with the right and people may listen to
this and say this guy is sadistic he's
crazies know if you know how I came up
you realized I was just a scared kid
that found Drive and passion to be
something much better than what he
thought he was that's all it is
self-talk and visualization of two keys
to my success I believed for that last
time 19 miles I was indestructible
because I took myself in that chair
crapping up my back peeing blood in my
leg shin splint stress fractures I used
all that for motivation versus
negativity I use it for motivation I
said to myself who on this earth would
still be going right now you are you are
you got to be the hardest on the planet
is it true I don't give at that time it
got me to the finish line of that race I
believed it I believed it today I
believed it enough to where my body said
he's not going to stop and that's I took
all the negative things I need to go to
the hospital this and that and I uses
all who the hell could even get on that
chair you did who the hell would even
think about taping stress fractures up
you did
all those things I'd use for motivation
what's the point of living you know a
lot of us go through our daily day
routine kiss the wife kiss the husband
whatever you're doing and that's our
life you know I believe everybody's put
on this earth for a journey and
everybody's journey is different but
most people don't know take their
journey they try and take an easier path
so that's what it's all about you gotta
accept your journey and a lot of times
your journey sucks but that's what you
gotta do it's always about giving back
you know God gave me a gift you know a
gift to kind of achieve ready to achieve
you know a strong mind and if I can kind
of relay that message to these young
kids young young men and women it's just
uh have these events around it's just
this helps them out ups and growing kids
the mentors nowadays yes and and they
hear of positive message from people who
don't have much know that hey I can do
it yes is all about you'll need much to
become a lot I started doing this
triathlons and endurance sports ultra
runs just to test my soul to see them
about to see in a hundred and fifty mile
race at Mile 75 when I feel really bad
that's when you know that's the only
time you can find out what even buy is
all about what you're made of
to find out limits to myself limits of
the human soul and every day I'm trying
to see if I have limits
[Music]
I run anywhere from 125 150 in a week so
I'll try and put in about 400 miles a
month usually every day I wake up at 3
o'clock in the morning and I run
anywhere from 10 to 15 miles in the
morning and then I live about 25 miles
from work so I get my bicycle commuting
to work do a normal work day at
lunchtime around noon I'll run again
and you where from 5 to 8 miles whatever
maybe come back work and around 5:30
arrive back home
25 miles on my bike if I'm feeling good
you know I'm gonna get more miles I'll
get off the bike and do like a short 3
or 4 or 5 mile run that's my everyday
life so I don't just train like an hour
or so I train until something is
uncomfortable and then that's when you
know who you are the only easy day was
yesterday it just never ends I mean I've
done some races where you're on a
one-mile track and you're a run for 48
hours straight so imagine running 48
hours running my mile track it's not
like you're sleeping you're you're
running for 48 hours and send me miles
you can get I want to talk about mind
torture
my life doesn't have a finish line so
when I cross that finish line of the
Ironman doesn't matter because I know
that you know two or three weeks from
now I'll be doing something else if I
bite through more pain
[Music]
I believe you know everything I try to
do is kind of define by excellence but I
don't think I ever reach excellence
myself because I have my standards of my
life a really high so I don't ever reach
it but I try to every day
you have to be a good individual first
before you can be a good team player I
know for a fact how bad he'll dig it I
went through a couple times it's part of
the most brutal military training
anybody go through it's everybody to my
left and everybody to my right they've
been through this so I know milli you
know these individuals are extremely
hard and when stuff gets bad and you
know in any situation I know these guys
have my back
[Music]
I've done a lot of things I thought were
impossible nothing's impossible anymore
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because M GOP official
asked me to if there's someone you'd
like to vote on for the next top ten
check out the link in the description
and go and have your say finally I
wanted to give a quick shout out to
Michael Shawn Phillips from lead the
team Michael thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and for doing the review on your
website I really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
what power have you found in the
darkness first I will be for answer that
question I want to say everybody listen
to this I'm the happiest man on the
planet Earth so people may take this and
as so many people do we live in a very
weakened society so when they hear a
throwback guy like me from back in the
ancient days of Garanimals they often
think this guy's just whatever so if you
think that I'm some unhappy guy you're
wrong having lived a life I've lived in
seeing the other side not being afraid
to attack what was in front of me has
made me happy to say that again and in
fact let me make sure I understood it
getting to the point where you're not
afraid to face the thing on the other
side of the door that wants to attack
you has made you happy right right it's
really powerful I hope people heard that
right it made me very happy so basically
I just don't walk around with a daggone
smile my face all the time so you know
Merry Christmas but but basically what
the dark side is is we all have a cookie
jar and we all have a jar
that's its official name it's a jar of
Man which just it's just ain't going
right and in hell week what they do in
hell week because this is where I really
went to the dark side we're they're
doing hell week is they designed hell
week to find your flaws and they do a
really good job of that it's 130 hours
of continuous training you may get two
hours of sleep and they beat this data
you will find everything wrong with your
mentality and then they start hell week
and that's the beauty of it and for me
I'm not some not no nasty guy giving guy
you know I don't have a great bit of
talent in anything so what got me
through horrible times was the dark side
whereas I created my name is David
Goggins I created Goggins Goggins is the
guy that can take anything you put in
front of them
you want to break my legs so be it
I have a way of going to a place like I
did in that race where all the pain and
suffering that they put on top of me in
hell week I will reverse that pain and
suffering and I will take your soul so
every instructor
that put me through buds my job what
drove me was I wanted you to go home
that night after you beat the living
[ __ ] out of me and I smiled in your face
I wanted you to feel worse than I did
and you were going home to a nice warm
bed with your wife or your kids in a
nice meal and I was still out there in
the grip suffering for another 100 hours
I want you to think about me knowing
that I'm comfortable being very
uncomfortable and I want you to think
about when you went to hell week how
uncomfortable you were and how bad you
wanted to quit knowing I'm not thinking
that way so the dark side is something
that I've designed it's an evil place I
can go that very few things can hurt me
I used to hurt you're trying to put on
me I flip it upside down and use it you
try use it for kryptonite know its power
pillows for me I'm using it for strength
I flipped negative into positive Saudis